foreign
about to jump in this scorn
put the food down unprofessional
I might have to turn this on and off
well you may have got a controller I
definitely got a controller
all right let me
make this to where uh I don't have to
worry about
do not disturb there we go
all right so I'm gonna turn down the
game stream just a tad
because I want you guys to be able to
hear me
over this
this game
oh the the the music by itself is
creeping me out by itself
I don't know what you guys got me up in
here doing
I hear myself somewhere there we go
all right let me uh
why don't you guys do me a favor man why
don't you share
me
on Twitter tell people the addict is
streaming scorn right now on the iron
Lords podcast channel so I could uh so I
can do less work
can you guys do that for me
can you do that for me
very curious if you guys can do that for
him
the title screen is creepy
what am I doing
all right here we go here you go here we
go bam
got him all right all right this is what
I'm gonna do
what is that
someone message me on Facebook
see I can't even unlock it because my
hands are still a little
a little spicy because of the uh
because of the chips I shouldn't eat the
chips
where I got myself into can't even
unlock my phone
drive them hands off Ash I will one day
one day
one day I'll do it great puzzle game
this don't look like a puzzle game man
this looks like my worst fears
that's what this game looks like it
looks like my worst fears
you guys got me all messed up great
puzzle game
all right all right all right chat
right now
tell me what the brightness should be
people that have played the game
tell me what that brightness should be
I'm curious I'm curious to hear your
guys's opinion on what you think I
should put the brightening on
equal I need to jump off of this soon
because the it's creepy it's creepy I
think I think this game's going to be
issues for me
it's creepy man it's creepy all right
let's
50 60. all right so like around here we
go to around here
it's over okay
we're gonna do right there
that title screen fam
that title screen
what's look at this title screen
you know I'm gonna move my mic a little
bit I'm gonna move my mic a little bit
look at this title screen it looks like
me getting up in the morning I ain't
gonna be roads dude that doesn't look
like me getting up in the morning
you know I I'd be a little bit
messed up can't see very well this looks
like what I would look like if I got up
in the morning
his eye looks messed up there's a lot of
Gore in this
I feel like I should bleach my eyes just
looking at this screen
we're gonna go
oh let me let me Zoom this
let me keep it down here I'm going to
keep it off of uh dual mode so you so I
can keep track of everything look at
this look at this is this what you guys
want
I gonna open watch it ten bucks Maybe
I knew what was gonna happen and I still
jumped I still jumped
you know those
you know those like in Alien movies when
they grabbed the people and take them
off and you never see them again this is
the perspective of someone who done got
jumped and grabbed and they still alive
it's creepy too
what's up hustle
how do you live
that was a very
that's creepy
that's creepy guys
he's just sitting there looking look how
detailed this game is though I agree
with you hustle this game is a
phenomenal looking game so far
you know but I feel like they're going
to take those graphics and put them
where they should be you guys feel me
man we bout to see the most detailed
blood and most detailed body parts known
to man that we really shouldn't be
seeing
I want to see how you perform on the day
of the first hand puzzle
look bad I'm gonna perform horrible
because I I
okay so that don't work
oh
Moving on Up Moving On Up
in this creepy tall way
oh this is
this is some creepy stuff if I lived
here
I would be lit 24 7. I I wouldn't I
would not be around not high if if I
lived in a place like this
I don't know man I don't know
it's a four out of ten I did see uh
acg's review which was funny I saw him
put it in there that um
he was like what's what score
Alfie okay
oh what's that sound
oh God
sounded like an elevator of some sort
I guess I gotta have something combat in
this game sucks I'll be the judge of
that song King I'll be the judge of that
gets a six out of 10.
I don't like the way the body parts be
looking man
uh
the sound of that
is so
horrible
what you doing man
I I know you got you got a hand what are
you supposed to do with the hand
quick thoughts so far addict weird
creepy
told you man after this I'm gonna take
some bleach to my eyeballs I feel like
that that will cleanse me of what I'm
seeing now
oh what what
is this
what is this oh my God oh my God what
about the [ __ ] why is this so low
why is this so low
it's like
oh my God let me
huh
ah okay okay
all right let's see
all right so you put your hand in it it
definitely grabbed it I don't know why
he didn't see that
I did touch it
I love how he's just so accepting that
he has that now
I would be more concerned who why that
was put on my arm than concerned about
whether or not it comes out as a spike
or not
hey let's just put your hand in other
stuff
just put it in some more stuff while
we're at it
I'm stuck oh okay okay
all right so
all right there we go there we go
how do I get out though
I I've opened up the door let me out
can I keep this cool glove though
how do I get out
I'm good I'm good can I can I leave
I should
oh
[Music]
they gave me a little bit too much time
to get in that you you had to have like
been like you had to have been like
drinking something to not realize you
can get in that
uh there was a bike outside and I
thought it was an enemy
[Music]
oh
creepy man creepy you know what I will
say about this game so far is it does a
good job immersion it gives a good job
making me feel like I'm in this weird
place now is that a good thing probably
not but I do feel like
the the sound cinematics that's going on
right now you know how detailed the hand
is when he puts it in and how you like
you know when you saw the blood coming
down your your wrist when you got this
little Stinger thing put on I feel like
that's good immersion tactics and that I
like that they did that
this looks like some you know what I'm
in a Hellraiser game that's what's going
on now
I'm in a Hellraiser game
can I sit down
foreign
Hellraiser Pinhead is the final boss in
this game Pinhead is the final boss in
this game
what is that
and why is it moving
explain to me why that's moving
I'm not stupid I see that movie
that's clearly moving
same stuff man I don't know what I'm
doing in this game
[Music]
it's another one of these things
except for that one's a lot bigger
all right so that clearly didn't stick
okay I get you
the immersion is a little bit too good
if I may add myself like listen just let
me redo this and you guys just listened
to him putting his fingers and whatever
whatever these like little glove things
are just listen hold up let me let me
turn up the capture card I'm not going
to talk during it
[Music]
weird man weird
no Alpha don't don't be talking about no
no VR we don't want that VR stuff in our
life especially this game
you know VR is pretty cool actually I
like the Oculus but I you wouldn't catch
me dead
playing this game
in VR
is that like a toilet
am I supposed to like sit on it
oh my God hold up let me see this again
all right so
that lifts the little middle parts
and the middle parts is what's stopping
him from being able to open it
all right so
yeah I kind of figured I need something
else to
do that
okay
okay
there's something over there
what does this do
okay hold up hold up
maybe that'll go in the little hole over
there
that's another way you can move it is
this way
all right so let's let's let's look
let's look around
so that one goes there
this one
you just it seems like you dump it
I ain't long lie to you man this this
game creeping me out
it's getting creeping me out
so it does look like it is a puzzle game
life Supremacy oh well no you didn't say
that uh Alpha
um I think they should have did a better
job marketing this to like I don't play
puzzle games do I look like the kind of
Dude to play puzzle games
they say I I lose my my stuff too quick
to be playing puzzle games
oh here we go
thank you
open
what is going on here
this is some very creepy stuff
it looks like it's all on Rails though
so that can move
uh I wouldn't say it would be a short
stream
you know
do you see scoring being a one-off title
I'm gonna reserve my uh my opinions on
scoring for IOP
and uh if I decide to give some kind of
form of a review then maybe for the most
part if you guys you know you'll get my
in general First Reactions to some of
this game but if you're going to want
like actual in-depth thing you're going
to want to go to IOP this Sunday
clearly I can't open that
I don't really really want to open that
I feel like you know if if I was this
dude opening a couple of these doors
like there's no
there's no character development so far
which is weird because if you're getting
like stuff grabbing it on your hand and
you're in this kind of area when you
just woke up like kind of encased into
the ground one would think that
it would be a lot more of a character
development with this guy does that make
sense
like because that's some pretty
traumatic stuff I feel like you would
you would want
to
to promote this character better
so we're looking for some form of a hand
I believe I believe so
some form of a hand
um I definitely messed up not making the
game a little bit brighter I should have
done that
the merch the motion blur on this is
kind of horrible can I change that
yes
hey if you you guys didn't see nothing
you didn't see nothing all right mind
your business mind your business
okay that's clearly not the way to go
I don't know maybe you have to
because I don't think you could do them
both
because the moment you do this when it
goes the other one
okay so that's not the way to go I feel
like we gotta find something chat to
like put into that perspective
what is this
isn't this how I got my ability
now this is a different one
okay
[Music]
yes we're using it
I guess we're not using it
[Music]
we're using it let's go
okay
all right
all right see what this does it probably
does a little rotation thing oh
really
really
you know what would have been funny this
was if this was a multiplayer type of
game or a co-op game and I told like
kids move to get in that and then I just
come over here and and push that and
just made that thing just slice his ass
in half
that would have been funny see I just
gave them an ideal they should have
listened to me
did you guys do the Scoopa or the saw uh
look guys I don't really care too much
about like backwards back seat gaming or
anything like that give me a couple
minutes to try to figure it out myself
um I'm not really a big on puzzle games
besides like Zelda games I I do want to
tempt it myself but after maybe another
five ten minutes if I'm not getting it
go ahead and tell me whoever knows so
that way we can move on to another part
of the game too because I know
realistically and I'm doing this for you
guys do you think I want to play scoring
look at the game do you think I want to
play scoring no I don't especially now I
know that it's like a puzzle game I'm
doing it because you know some people
was hitting me up asking me to do it
what is this
[Music]
what the hell
oh so I'm fixing the railings
all right where would it potentially
start so I think it would start up here
it's going to go down
I think we'll probably want to go off
that we'll try that first
again I'm gonna turn it back up and you
guys listen to the sound this makes it
creeps me out this is like I don't do
good with certain notation that sounds
like whispering and like the way Hellboy
does their game where they whisper in
your ear it creeps me out I don't like
that stuff this is worse listen I'ma
turn it up
foreign
[Music]
it's like they suffocating me with a
giant mirror or something like that I
don't know meaty a s m r we ain't don't
ever say that again Brian don't ever say
that again I don't want to ever
hear you say that again
[Music]
thought we were friends right I thought
we were friends
guess we're not
now what is this this is probably how
you control the little thing
oh what is this is that gonna start the
no
[Music]
what what
oh this game man this game this game
it's creepy it's creepy I feel like you
have to grab that somehow
let's try it again let's try it again
I'ma grab that
get down there
maybe you have to rotate it
all right go to the elevator I get it
you guys getting tired of me being stuck
here I get it
let me see what this does first
foreign
creepy
I don't know what you guys got me
playing
I don't know man I'm just creeped out
just thinking about this game
someone said elevator I'm at the
elevator
you happy
let's go up
[Music]
what is this
man they
they got so many useless things useless
cranes I bet you this moves it
hold up
oh
okay
does anything pop out can you go down
yes you can
this one over here pops out
[Music]
all right so you can move these
individually
[Music]
can I move these
okay so you can move these individually
there's got to be
a goal maybe I get these over here
all right so that's not gonna work
can it go up
[Music]
let's move it over
let's do it
this one over here is like a different
color our everything about this is like
that red bloodish looking thing very
creepy
foreign
let's try this
all right can I move this one over here
many goes all the way over here
[Music]
all right let me look
took me 30 minutes to figure this out
you have to put the red one with the
light
what the light is oh okay all right so I
get you
yeah I said I even I even realized that
that was something that is different
it's just I didn't realize uh I probably
would have tried it eventually here's my
thing like with me streaming man I'm not
okay look
no heat to people that care about boxy
game because I understand it if you're
streaming like a lot I feel like
backseat gaming would get on your nerves
but to me I feel like backseat gaming is
just the audience wanting to make the
stream better for them if that makes
sense
oh can I go up with it yeah
yeah what happens if
if I go up
oh and then grab it again okay I get you
man
[Music]
with the light
all right so let me let me read some of
this this stuff that I've started here
[Music]
um
oh yeah I see what you mean now
true they want it to go by smooth that's
what I'm saying like I feel like a lot
of backseat and obviously there's going
to be jackasses there's no denying I
feel like a lot of people just want the
stream to be more entertaining and you
know for the most part I've never really
cared about vaccine gaming I was like I
had people
oh oh
[Music]
[Music]
that was creepy
[Music]
all right so I bet you there's a hand in
that
I bet you 20 bucks there's a hand in
that
let's go look
because I think I think uh he ripped it
off and it fell down I think there's a
hand guys I think we have ourselves a
hand fresh one off off the Rocks man
fresh and off the rice
[Music]
is this it
is this what fell
everything's so bloody in this game it's
hard to tell
the rail system that means it would have
fell around this area
[Music]
oh my God okay hold up
let's back see game here ourselves here
okay what are your thoughts on Gotham
Knights being capped 30 frames this is
so ridiculous considering the GPU CPU
and DSi with the current consoles
uh I might talk about that uh let me let
me get these backseat Gamers okay
can you fall down there I don't know I
don't know what you're talking about can
I fall down there you're not finished
that one failed oh so I didn't do it
right okay
okay addict he had one job one job and
you couldn't even do that right I can't
even use a crane correctly
[Music]
I could put my fingers in the places
where they shouldn't be that's for sure
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
are you gonna do a full playthrough of
this game probably not
you got to pluck the other one off that
it's connected to another one
[Music]
it looks like there's another one over
there maybe that's what they're talking
about
you gotta plug the other one until they
patch it
Oh wrong one I gotta do that other one
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
I can't move it that way
let's try putting this over here
because I only really need that middle
section
foreign
oh so there's two
[Music]
okay
I can't move this down because there's
not two of those down there
[Music]
bam
all right
can these move down
yes they can can I move it left a little
bit
yes I can
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
hold up guys
all right so now let's start rotating
stuff back
slowly though well we probably don't
want to rotate that completely back
because it is going up and down
is this just one
[Music]
thank you
all right so now let's start well you
can't rotate these right because uh
[Music]
hold up I gotta get that one out of here
before I do anything
this is making it hard to do anything
foreign
[Music]
let's move this up right
can I move these down
so I don't think I can go that way with
that
foreign
go to the top one that's right
[Music]
hold up
foreign
over
[Music]
the
left
get these ones you can move them down
here on these singular ones
let's move this way let's try right
there first
just trying to get these to the right
first
I see you guys giving me advice give me
a second I'll get to it
all right all right so let's let's look
what you guys have to say can't move in
empty spaces I I'm pretty sure move all
the paws to the right and lit in the
left one left I was trying that
worry about the lateral pieces are you
talking about like just the individual
ones is that what you're talking about
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
talking about this one over here
well it won't let me go that far
I'm assuming the one that you guys are
referring to
is this this piece that's lit up
[Music]
all right so are we talking about this
one right here the one I have
thank you
okay so we got that done
we've established communication
BLT
I don't know yet we'll have to say leave
the lit one right and start moving the
others
all right so
I try to move the other ones right but
the problem is you need that top piece
[Music]
[Music]
all right let me see if this works
hey hold up let's move this down
[Music]
so that gives me a little bit of room a
little bit of wiggle room
no ignore me you moved out since I wrote
that oh see it's kind of hard to uh
work this out considering you guys are
like a 10 second layer layout should I
bring kids smooth in so he could just
tell me how to do it or do one of you
want to jump in a party with Smith and
tell me how to do it
yeah because I go sit here all day I
ain't sitting here all day I mean
what's up uh Faye I assume it's Fame
you know what we gonna do
someone put a link someone put a link
Link in the chat
tell me how to do it put a link in the
chat
or send me a link on Twitter and I will
bring it up live on stream and we're
going to solve this
Link in the chat
[Music]
Link in the chat
get the light bunch of the fourth row to
move things over the fourth row fourth
row
down
or fourth row left
so technically it would be this one
[Music]
referring to
[Music]
okay hold up hold up
see what happens if I get
this to like the last one maybe I can
maneuver just enough to get it up and
around
all right let's move it down
hold up
[Music]
so let me
put these back here
nope don't do that I've clearly messed
things up man I've clearly messed things
up all right someone someone in the chat
right now I prefer someone I know uh
because I know I I don't know all of you
but uh
someone I know life Supremacy I'm pretty
sure you've done Community IOP nights
send me a party invite let me let
actually let me
let me go here online
let me appear online
someone sent me a party
I'm I'm down I'm down man someone sent
me apart anyway
we ain't doing this I can send smooth a
party invite
but
I don't know
he might flip out I don't know how long
have you spent on this like 30 minutes
for BLT I'm not spending any longer on
it someone in the realm enlightened me
on the way to get to the light pod to
the left side of the map
one of you have the answer
one of you two
[Music]
there you go live Supremacy for the win
all right give me a second while I
change
let me change the uh
foreign
I gotta change the uh account so uh they
can hear you
all right there we go
all right now they should be able to
hear you all right live Supremacy
enlighten me in the ways
all right
I'm not gonna move unless you tell me
too
uh
and move out on big pieces to the uh to
the left
so like the twos
yeah
all right
[Music]
do you not mean the uh the light one do
I keep that on the right
oh move that one over there
okay
stop moving all the way
back son
bring the light one back son okay
back one or two
back up bring it back all the way up
[Music]
all right I'm gonna give this a couple
seconds
foreign
Bring It Forward one okay
[Music]
all right so uh now
you see the single one at the bottom to
the left
and move move the white one down
it's a single one that underneath it
yeah I know I did that do I move the
white one down now
I know I did that wrong with the white
one down
yeah
I try to bring all the single ones over
to the
to the left to the right side
[Music]
okay hold up
so I want them at the three behind them
right
yeah
well don't move that one right there
right
yeah kind of are you screaming
all right move the right one up
man we got Talia here say bra
all right now what
we got Talia here saying bro
all right now
put on the single ones
all right they're at the bottom
all right
you see that fourth po that got a three
up there I think I know now
all right
I think I know
kind of want more
yeah you gotta move that same one over
gentlemen what's going on what's going
on
attic what's going on bro hello
I gotta get that one right here
especially
Co-op no no no no
[Music]
uh no I don't I'm about to leave the
party anyway I just needed uh he helped
me with that part I'm not sitting here
for hours on these things man
oh yeah
all right attic I'm looking forward to
this show tomorrow
in the building listening oh yeah
there's that is that a dead body
all right all right I'll talk to you
guys later
I appreciate it like
all right
[Music]
that's creepy I ain't gonna lie to you
guys
that's creepy
oh no he's not dead okay
[Music]
oh let's not get stuck how about that
let's go back downstairs
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
where is it
[Music]
all right he's definitely moving
oh that's creepy
[Music]
what's up homie
you look like you've had a bad day
how many limbs you got one
two well no you
seem like you need help
we need to name him what do you guys
want to name him
what should we name him
that's creepy
it's looking at him creeps me out man
Richard
we're gonna name him Richard all right
let's name him Richard
[Music]
the crap Gabriela be nice guys
what did I just do foreign
[Music]
you okay Richard
seem like you still alive
hey you see like a little bit more
messed up than you was
it's okay Richard we got more stuff in
tune for you man
we got more stuff for you Richard
don't hold your hand out it's too late
Richard you came to the wrong place
what you doing Richard there's nothing
up there for you Richard
[Music]
you're okay Richard
if you thought that was cool Richard I
got something crazy for you now
[Music]
hold up Richard you're gonna love this
one second Richard
we got something for you
let's go Richard
I'm gonna put you in that Richard
does I feel better Richard
all right Richard
thank you
let's go Richard
[Music]
[Music]
bye Richard
[Music]
this is creepy man
I ain't gonna lie to you guys
I fell away I fell away
look he's just holding the hand out
while he's running
all right hold up hold up
[Music]
all right so I can't do it that way do I
need two hands
[Music]
we got the hand though guys we got it
oh yeah see I had to take him to the
other room I'll get you now
[Music]
oh look how creepy that hand is
okay
[Music]
hold on I'll read the chat here in a
second guys
I'm getting kind of confused how the
room is I need to find another one of
those rooms that lets me stick his hand
in it I just don't know where it's at
where is it
that's not it
it's in one of these rooms
oh yeah it's in that room
I got to get back in there
I might have to go upstairs
[Music]
what's in here
[Music]
no okay so it is downstairs
oh yeah someone did say I gotta put
something on his hand
yeah I kind of figured that because
it wouldn't go incorrectly I just got to
figure out where it was
oh right here
[Music]
what was that sound
[Music]
he's gonna let go of it start closing
[Music]
I wonder if I can go back and get that
arm that arm scene is very useful
with situations where I don't want to
use my arm
no the arm is gone
I'm okay with that to a point
[Music]
come on
is it gonna start closing
it's too inconsistent
what's up sarcaster
foreign
so there's no eating playing this game I
got you
that's creepy
[Music]
guess you need some other kind of
upgrade
[Music]
[Music]
all right what is this
[Music]
[Music]
like here's my biggest thing with this
game is I this is such a unique world
that I feel like they're not really
taking advantage of in terms of like
lore and stuff
that's my big thing is I feel like they
can do more with this game if if like
they expanded on the lore like
what are we doing here
what is that
[Music]
was creepy
I'm assuming out to get something to
move in that
this is a creepy game
wow
probably give you guys another uh 45
minutes to an hour of this
what's going on here
I guess I'm gonna just keep exploring
[Music]
I just feel like
missed opportunities with this type of
game
like don't get me wrong I'm really
enjoying like the atmosphere of the game
obviously it's a little creepy the
atmosphere is extremely creepy
I don't know if I agree with that George
I don't know if I agree with that I feel
like
I feel like you want lower shoved down
your throat in games
you know you want to expand on the
universe to the game you're playing
I feel like you know telling me visually
is one thing but not explaining anything
is another
I will say that the game runs very good
I've had no issues yet
I'll also say that you know the
immersion is
on the real this is some of the best
immersion I think that I've seen in the
game in a very long time
but when there's nothing showing you of
the immersion and it's just immersion I
think that's where you might miss me at
now I'm not saying that they can't do a
good job further on in the game because
I haven't beat the game obviously but
currently it would have been nice to
explain what you are clearly I don't
know if you're alive or you're dead or
you're maybe some form of like a zombie
or something like that I don't know why
you're here I don't even know what
you're doing are you trying to leave the
place are you trying to uh you know I
would I would assume you're trying to to
escape
but
that's up in the air too because
it feels like he's never been here
said I need to pull the pull thing off
hold up
oh oh
okay no I honestly didn't see him for
some reason
[Music]
yeah I feel you
[Music]
and I don't mind answering questions or
or asking questions but I do feel like
they could have did a better job
explaining the universe of scoring
like I don't think no one's gonna say
that scorn is a bad game I mean
obviously you got the haters and Scorn
isn't every game that comes out isn't
supposed to apply to everyone you know
I see the potential in something like
scoring actually you know what this
gives me like a really good vibe of like
Dead Space
you know I think Dead Space is another
game that does uh you know immersion
very well
foreign
[Music]
that's what I thought so do I drive this
thing
it looks like that's what actually
caused this stuff though
so what did this thing look like
all right
is this another one
it
so it does look like you have to grab
these things
I think
all right hold up hold up
let me move this over here maybe those
things pop up
no nothing popped up
hold up
is there another one of these like a
higher platform
Maybe
hold up
is there another one of these somewhere
yeah there's a little pathway going up
nothing there though
all right someone said there's a a
weapon that's also a key go back okay
are we talking about that one that's in
that room
there's nothing there
was something here that I couldn't get
earlier
away
all right I'm looking
I'm looking for the whole
to put my thing in
where is it
[Music]
forward from the elevator
[Music]
he's a very creepy game man and
you know
one thing this game does very good
that's creepy is it does a good job at
oh my God that scared me I don't know
why that scared me
[Music]
ew
hey
chat why don't you mess with me
I got something for you
all right so I assume I use these now
yeah combat talk will be with the king
at I believe 10 P.M
I don't know I I said it as 10 p.m but I
don't know if that's actually what he is
going to do it
[Music]
okay
foreign
what is that
can these things hurt me
[Music]
I'm pretty sure they can hurt me
I don't know why
We're not gonna find out though
we're gonna take them out chat we're not
finding out these things can hurt or not
there's a few of them
what's up
there's another one here
uh
uh is he above me yeah he's right here
it's hard the reach on this thing is
trash
are we
I wish we had more of reach
than we actually do that would be nice
let's just leave them there
I ain't worried about that
[Music]
or maybe you do have to kill them
I guess they'll just kill them real
quick
[Music]
come on man
why are you on the parts of the map I
can't reach very very easily
I don't like games like that
is this another one of those things
yeah it is there's one on each side I
guess
looks like a spine dude
very creepy very creepy
see I would want
the generalization of fear that I have
right now
being on like something like dead space
I feel like they do really good job on
that like for the most part on Dead
Space you get to a point where you don't
really fear the enemies as much anymore
uh and you know I'm generally frightened
of these things I don't know what they
do
you know it does look like after killing
a couple I'm fine
all right so
there's two more I'm pretty sure we have
to use this little robot again
to grab them I'd assume
[Music]
yeah I would feel I'll feel you on that
it's more uh creepy than scary I feel
you I think that's a good uh word more
creepy than scary
[Music]
well we'll probably do chat is here in a
minute after I do this
probably called a wrap for this and
might do like a little after thing uh to
talk about some of the topics you guys
been putting in the in the chat
[Music]
demoing cholesterol protocol I'm hoping
I have a review code for that game to be
honest with you
oh what is that
[Music]
gotta grab this one now
hmm
[Music]
I like how they have like a good
diameter around what that is to actually
put it in I like that because it gives
it that that Sensation that you don't
have to exactly be accurate when you're
trying to use these weird machines to
put them in
because sometimes that would get
annoying if you had to keep going like
left or right to actually get a good
Center balance to be able to put them in
[Music]
foreign
creepy stuff man
more creepy stuff
down with the creep man down with the
creepy stuff
I just got us killed that's what
happened
that was creepy
gives you a lot of achievement so I
think that's like
what is this
creepy
look at my new legs man they they
smashing man
I've been Reborn
I'm a new I'm a new man now
was that coming out of his his growing
area was that a little
giant skeleton of some sort that's kind
of creepy
is something eating it or mooching off
of it oh it's coming out of its stomach
[Music]
oh what is that thing
where are we
oh my God man
that was some creepy stuff
that was some creepy stuff
look at this thing
this dude's had a bad day
he had a really bad day
probably had his lottery ticket stolen
his winning lottery ticket
what are you talking about smooth
oh so this is a different one
all right so just to clarify you're a
different person now is that what you
guys are saying
is that what you guys are saying
that you're a different person now
oh okay
see
the sad part about it is that's a cool
concept
but I have no no details to why it's a
cool concept
um
you know
at this probably as far as I'm gonna go
let me uh
let me set up a little
all right
all right we're good we're good
let me
all right so this is the aftermath man
after man you know what hold up hold up
hold up
I know what I'm gonna do
why can't I hear
what can I hear
is it because it's not
no it's in the speakers
what's going on man
oh there we go
there we go
oh I ran out of room that's why it was
messing up
okay okay I ran that room
all right
all right so we're not going to talk
about scoring too much there's some
stuff that people want me to talk about
uh particularly the 30 frames stuff I
ain't buying Gotham Knights it's not
happening there's nothing that you can
make me buy that game now
and I advise everybody
in the chat
to not buy Gotham knights we must show
these developers that we ain't playing
you don't make a good copy of something
you don't get dealt with
plus I heard that
one of the developers was Loki trying to
blame uh Xbox for that or something
related to that I don't know
[Music]
how is the Xbox's fault that's what I
want to know
not even a Scooby Snack what you mean
I don't know what you mean by not even a
Scooby Snack
you have to be a little bit more uh
clear on that one
so what you guys want to talk about man
you guys got me for about 20 minutes man
20 minutes
and then I'ma I'm gonna do something
else maybe I'll go well no the girl
don't get off till nine
and I'll probably be slowly heading to
sleep by then so I don't know if that's
why is not being 60 frames bad
it's because I think when I started
playing PC gaming uh at the end of the
Xbox One and PS4 generation I really
found out how important it is to have a
60 frames game
and I think that's what really put me in
that mindset that I need that 60 frames
like and I don't even think 60 frames is
the end-all be-all I think it's more
about
the the
field of view I think the field of view
isn't utilized as much as as I would
like I think that is way more important
thank you
I'm confused as what to do in the game
uh what are you referring to Winter
on scorn
uh am I getting bayed out of three
probably not after I saw that nonsense
that was uh put on there did you see
that they were the chick who played
bayonet and the other ones I didn't even
know she wasn't playing Bennett and this
they're often are four thousand dollars
two voice recorded an entire game
that's insane to me
what part are you at winter
you have to be a little more specific on
where you at
because I don't know I don't know
yeah four thousand dollars to play the
entire Bayonetta rule I don't blame it
for not doing it I wouldn't have done it
either
it's kind of like ridiculous that unless
you're like one of the bigger people
that yeah that would that would have
been more on Platinum than Nintendo but
she did tag Nintendo on it so I think
maybe Nintendo has a little bit at the
very beginning
are you talking about
um
I mean what you could do uh winter is
you could uh
you can
rewind the stream because this isn't
twitch you can actually rewind the
stream and actually see what we were
doing in there
if that makes sense to you
considering there's a lot of dialogue in
those games for the most part it's
insulting
I'd have been upset too
we gotta stand up for these people man
they they they help bring the games that
we love to life
you know don't don't buy Bayonetta
yeah I think I think that has a lot more
to do with
with Nintendo then
then Platinum Nintendo probably didn't
give them a lot of money to make the
game off in the first place
what's up Gerald Mack
yeah that's what I'm saying
you know if they get a budget and they
can't go over that budget I can
understand why
they would have a hard time going over
that budget so I I get it I get it I'm
not gonna say it's good or bad but I do
think that uh they need to be a little
bit better on that
you know especially offering her four
thousand dollars
four thousand dollars man if you offer
me four thousand dollars to do that
amount of work everything's gonna be
phoned in
and you're getting one take that's all
that's all one take
yeah she said the first two games made
450 million dollars
imagine making that much money and
offering the voice of the main character
four thousand dollars
to make a sequel to make the the third
installment of the franchise
it's sad that's why I always say man
you know
is there a such thing as a lazy Dev
that's that's subjective
uh because I feel like you can never
know where the the publisher
of get this out the door quick and the
the quote unquote lazy
picks up
uh because I feel like if you would ask
any developer they would want the best
product possible
yeah what are they called royalties she
should she should got royalties for sure
did they pay the same for the new VA
what's VA you have to be a little more
specific on that pentimental
pentamentals or I don't know I apologize
if I butchered your name
then again I don't really apologize
because you named yourself
you know
it's not my fault I can't pronounce it
oh voice actor
probably for only probably the same
thing
one second guys I gotta turn off my
camera just so my brother can get
something
uh but you know
it is oh pinnamon
um
I think I'm gonna try to get my hands on
that game you know I'm not the biggest
fans
of playing a game like that without
I don't know
my mindsets I want
I want a I want an RPG from obsidian if
that makes sense
and you know I grounded was different
and I'm still I was still initially
upset with grounded the one thing I got
to start doing better
is understanding that developers are
very wide in range in the kind of games
they can make and I can they can make
different forms of games I think I could
still be I think it's right to be you
know you know distance you know you're
being critical you know how is this
developer going to make this type of
game when they've made these type of
games but it's hard to separate the
studio from the individual developer
you know Forza going on to Fable sure
the studio has made nothing before the
games but it's going to be hard for me
to separate the studio from the
developers that are making fable
if that makes sense to you guys
are you guys going to link up for that
again probably next week I was
originally going to play this week
uh with just the newer people maybe one
Lord or maybe two if I could get it but
everyone was just so busy you guys you
know there's not a whole lot I could do
about that uh but hopefully here in the
next couple weeks we'll be able to uh
jump back on that I want to kill some
spiders I want to kill some spiders
and it was it was it was a blast I
really enjoyed it
uh for those of you that's in the chat
because I know that you know we still
have a let me exit out of that we still
got like a good almost 50 strong in here
you know watching me play scorn
for those of you in the chat you know
definitely uh go there and follow us on
tick tock
I will actually put it in the chat are
you reviewing the place so no I'm not I
don't have a copy of that yet I could
get it if I wanted to but I didn't play
the original one and to me
I do have connects to get stuff like
that and I'm pretty sure if I reach out
I could have got a game like that now
normally
I would review a game even if I'm not
interested if smooth because me and
smooth share a digital library I would
still get it if smooth wanted to play
like for instance
um there's a game he asked me for I'm
not really interested too much in
playing it but because I know smooth
wants to play and uh smooth
doesn't know if he'll be able to get a
copy you know he still might get a copy
of it I'm I asked for it even though
there's a good chance that I'll that
even if we do get it I'll have to review
it uh so that's going to take time out
of my day but you know when
sometimes you gotta do what you got to
do man and you know coverage on the IOP
channel is always good
it's not like it's never not good
thoughts on Dragon Ball Breakers what is
that
white culture you have to I I did see it
on the store I don't know what it is
though
is it just like a
like an updated on like the last one
Kakarot
you have to tell me what that exactly is
I'm using my phone to see how this the
the stream sounds okay it was just my
brother who called me my brother's
already here so I can't call him back
now
see how this stream sounds goes
all right so let's see
all right so let's see
I don't even hear the the background
yeah it's there it's just very light
oh what's up man uh Gotham fighter from
Sweden all right you know I've never
been out of the states I've always
considered doing it now IOP does want to
start going on more out of state stuff
but that stuff's kind of expensive uh so
we'll have to see right now we are
scheduled to go to like packs next year
maybe both packs is West and East and E3
but as far as like going to Gamescom
that that's up in the air
um we'll see we'll see man I really I
really
I'm kind of like nervous to do it to be
honest with you because I've never been
out of the out of the country like I got
like a an absurd fear of like not
knowing the culture somewhere and I
offend someone because of it
and I know that like
people in other countries probably are
accepting that because they know you're
not in their their culture but it's
still I don't want to offend no one
because I'm sure you know America do all
kinds of stuff differently
all kinds of stuff differently so I I
can assume that there's a lot of things
that we do different that most people
don't
oh you understand English you know
what's funny uh Galax fighter is that it
seems like the rest of the world is more
understanding to be bilingual bilingual
I think that's what it is where you know
more than one
um one language
it seems like
everyone in the world for the most part
at least knows two languages but
Americans I don't know what that's about
a lot of Americans clearly know two
languages but I feel like it's more
normal outside of America
and then we got like ridiculous
Americans that assume that everyone
needs to speak language uh language so
it I mean English which is is baffling
to me
you know what's funny is I always
thought that
you know I would learn another language
but clearly no Thomas says I'm from
France
uh what's up man France I ain't never
been to France
I've heard good things about friends but
I've never been to France
we might be going to the video uh to the
Tokyo game shows eventually Wells is
here what's where is Wells
I don't know what uh Wells is
hold up let me
let me put that in the in the handy
dandy Google
oh it's a UK constitutional country
that's what's up
it looks like it's by Dublin in London
see I think one of the coolest things
about the internet is you realize how
connected we truly are
I think that's one of the coolest things
about the internet is you really find
out how connected we are and how extra
people go out of their way to make sure
we're connected uh people don't realize
the
the
amount
of possibilities you have
that you didn't have years ago
and I think that's cool
uh someone said I want to go to Japan I
would love to go to Japan too
but your civil oh God we might have to
we might have to live I'm scared to do
live reactions on YouTube I don't want
to get the channel in trouble for
anything
we learned English at seven years old is
it is it galaxies is it mainly because
like
English is such an accepted language
that people feel like they need to learn
it or is it just something that you guys
want to learn I'm kind of curious what
that is if it's like something that you
guys want to do or is because Society
has moved so much towards language and a
lot of the key countries in the world
that it's just something that you
naturally have to eventually learn
um
Oh we must learn I mean I understand
that because people people want to make
sure that for the most part
anywhere and you know I feel like
Americans should be made to learn other
language too especially Spanish because
we we're so close to the Mexican border
and a lot of the native language there
is Spanish I feel like you know it's
very beneficial for us to learn Spanish
but for some reason that's not the way
America thinks they're like you know you
learned and most of us can't even speak
English I can't pronounce English half
the time
I'm looking at a
we know look man look man
it's more easy than other languages yeah
I've noticed when like if you look like
subtitles on Japan or Japanese
like Japanese says way more context
behind the same subtitles that's America
that's that's dubbed in English
subbed in English so it's kind of crazy
that a a fraction of a sentence sounds
way longer in Japanese
I think that's good though I think your
your Society sets you up to to succeed
you know I think maybe it's not his
issue here because we're not connected
to as many countries as like France and
tomorrow because if you look at like the
world map you guys are connected to a
lot of countries so I think it would
make more sense that you guys would need
to learn more stuff
uh because you know you're probably
going to run into people in that area
that speak that native tongue so it
would make more sense
I I think there's some people in the
community that teach English in Japan
the Lord's playing different kinds of
survival games would be dull what kind
of survival games you guys thinking
I'm curious
you guys got me for about another 13
minutes I'm out of here at seven
I got to play some more fortnite I'm
lacking on that
I appreciate some of you have a good day
yeah we'll definitely be uh
I don't know if we're having any like
guests popping in I'm looking at the
schedules clear we don't have a uh a
guest it doesn't look like what's the
15th so when I was the 16th
well we're in October
yeah so we're not having
um
any guests we are having a guest the
following week and I'm trying to reach
out to more people
that we've never had on
uh obviously I and I try to because
clearly it would make the most sense for
us to just uh you know we got into the
size now where we can benefit you know
bigger content creators to come on that
they would get uh you know an audience
that they've never heard of But I me and
Carl were the ones that mainly do the
guess you know we we were very vocal at
the beginning it doesn't matter how big
IOP gets clearly we're still gonna go
for bigger audiences because it will
bring people that's never heard of us
into the podcast but we always want to
make sure we give smaller content
creators a chance too
we don't need one you don't need what
Thomas it's like no layers and we have
similar languages dead by daylight DBZ
Breakers I'm gonna have to look at that
DBZ Breakers thing evolve recipe I loved
evolve like there's a video on my actual
YouTube channel playing evolved
and predator hunting grounds
uh a guest
I am okay all right here's the thing
about the guests we have cut back on the
gas from popular demand we clearly know
you guys like just us
and I love that because it used to be
back in the day
we would feel like we need big guests to
start bringing in a huge audience but
now we've gotten to the point so many
people have seen our you know our
Charisma our chemistry uh especially how
you know we try not to cuss as much as
possible especially me I'm the only one
that has really issues with that because
we want to make it to our and what's
funny is I was really against the
cussing thing like a hundred percent
against it and I was I was out voted
first off we run a democracy not a
dictatorship all of us have to agree or
the majority at least and most of the
time we all agree we rarely ever have
something where the majority pushes the
ideal through we usually always agree on
everything uh so that's good
y'all should have
what is
what is him I've never heard of him
call Phil
look I'm not saying much of much
we ain't ready to announce anything
uh but you know we are that is a focus
eventually
for King yeah that'd be nice I'm looking
at this uh Channel now
hold up
you know what we're gonna do
we're turning this into something else
man
all right so let me look here screen
display
screen capture
we want
screen
three
yes now let me close some of these out
though
let me close out the guest list because
if call if Cog let me show if like see
we usually have months uh in advance of
guests like it's kind of crazy how many
uh guests we usually stack up we'll get
like three or four months in advance uh
every couple months but it causes if if
[ __ ] found out I I let you guys see the
guest list it's a wrap
I'm out of a job
now why isn't it working there we go
let me put it at the bottom
so you guys can still see me
why can't the camera see me okay I gotta
put at the top
all right there we go
all right so is this the person that you
uh the person was referring to
let me
leave that go to this so I can do this
quicker
is this the person you guys were
referring to
yeah I reach out to him does he have a
Twitter account
of course he has a Twitter cat
everyone's got a Twitter account these
days
he's even got an email attached on his
Twitter
makes things a lot easier
let me uh let me write his name down
all right I wrote his name down
uh we will reach out
because I'm always looking to get
different perspectives we always want to
make sure we have people
that
we always want to have newer people we
always want to have newer people okay
give people chances that's for the most
part it's always been our our thing I I
like this channel
um
49 000 he's got pretty good subscriber
right man he's got way more than us
so y'all reach out to him if he if he
responds back sometimes these bigger
content creators don't respond but I'll
I'll reach out to him personally myself
kid smooth is uh
is asking me
how we got past the part let me
you shoot them
hold up
oh okay he he tagged us and stuff
all right let me go back over it's
important if you don't have guests just
for one show
um to be honest with you Thomas we're
gonna We're not gonna have guests for
the majority of the shows from now on
um you know we've we've gotten pretty
serious about just making sure it's just
us
all right so smooth sent me a message
let's see what the message says
I feel like that's where I was
I don't know though
is it is that where I was I feel like I
did that
I don't know though
uh is Santa one of your future guests no
Sam is not one of our future guests uh
you know we we we'll have them all man
we'll have them huh but he's not
bring good yeah we will you know I do
want to do more of those
Community things where we have a
different community on what podcast
would you guys want us to link up with
I'm curious on that is there a podcast
that you guys would like for us to link
up with
is there a podcast that you guys would
like that with
wbg RDX
uh Dart I'm pretty sure that starts
podcast
wbg
dirt's on the attic show so that
wouldn't be hard
love dirt dirt's a good dude
RDX yeah we can make the RDX won't
happen
um
what else we got we got 43 people in the
chat man I know some of you guys want to
see us collab with certain content
creators put that in the chat tell Adam
what you guys want man tell Isaac what
you guys want
but all you have to TTS
Griffin gaming I don't know if we'll
work with Griffin game
he kind of makes different content you
know we kind of try to keep the people I
don't know that's not I can't really say
that either because I do eventually want
to work with some of the other podcasts
and some of you guys might not
necessarily like uh like weapon will
really you know kid smooth BG and all
that's been really good to us so I would
love to you know maybe even have just a
wiper wheel and IOP Community today
where we all play fortnite you know if
we don't do the the podcasting part at
least do that
some PlayStation guide just for fun
I don't know Thomas I don't know
it's not a lot of PlayStation guys out
there that
frontenga the same thing with Griffin
like you know they they have like a
unique type of content
um normally we stay away from that form
of content because I feel like it
conflicts with ours a lot like we
usually try not to like make anything
personal and I'm not saying they make
anything personal uh but they do do a
lot of like you know beef videos such
and such and I wouldn't even I don't
personally think it's me videos you know
I do feel like sometimes they go too far
Alex we got Alex because I've always
felt like Alex does those videos like
really clean to a point where he's not
trying to make anything's personal MBG
absolutely not
um he has said some Choice words uh to
me once Griffin gaming actually made a
video about kids smooth once
I think the people just want some big
voices these days some up and coming
crazy oh yes so I said wandering Dutch
we're always going to go for the small
content creators uh you know you can
hear me on this channel for years saying
that I built this platform of Cognito
that was one of the things that we had
in mind was to not only hype up and and
bring up smaller content creators but
also Indie developers and you know
developers in general that have products
that we believe in
I think that's a very important thing
it put the logos in the chat man but the
logos in the chat
I wish I could gift
see Maybe not maybe not gift memberships
for me for the podcast I feel like we
should be able to give those podcasts
those memberships to people if we want
reforged gaming
uh I don't know who that is let me copy
and paste that game pass that's funny
Jimmy and Phil
Jimmy uh Jim Ryan is never going to come
to the podcast
let's keep that real guys Jimmy's never
come to the podcast
I like his content good thumbnails
oh let me go back to the main screen
I get R Kelly
I know he's got to get out of prison
first man he's got to get out of prison
first
let me turn off this and turn back on
the screen capture
I like these thumbnails whoever said
this dude these thumbnails are clean
straight to the point I like them
Dead Space new reverse dude dude got a
good solid Channel I would probably want
to use more of the left
uh more of this unused real estate right
here I probably would want to use more
of that but it's solid thumbnail solid
thumbnails
blessing from kind of funny all right uh
he doesn't really mess with us like that
uh but you know go on Twitter you know
tag him tag IOP and say you would love
to see him come on a guess if you guys
like and you prefer that you would see
someone you know go on there and tag
them tag them on Twitter show them that
you want to see them
I got to figure out how to make
thumbnails well here's
yeah let's go to my channel
so here's my personal Channel
and these are my thumbnails see I made a
video in a month I've been doing a lot
of things I my time's starting to like
settle back down I'm going to
restructure this channel
because I miss making content
uh you know I also do kids moves
thumbnails a lot for the most part all
his thumbnails here thumbnails I've done
so I mean you could see
I've done all these review thumbnails
yeah I mean you know maybe we can do
that I you you got a point there
all right see you Zen Castro I'm about
to close out of here anyway
kid smoothie and I don't be like that
smooth's a good dude
sharpayers could put in a good word yeah
spawn wave he don't really like respond
to me
like especially him in rgx I think is
his name he's not responded to me either
I even tried to get um
the chick that's on there too because I
I want to uh
you know get more women on the podcast
too because I feel like they have a
perspective rgt yeah they have a
perspective on gaming that you know men
doesn't have especially when it comes to
you know a lot of the the issues that
they go through on a day-to-day be
especially being a content creator I
couldn't imagine sometimes what it's
like being a content creator as a woman
yeah I'm sure it's it's it's horrible
sometimes
I use paint.net
I use this program my computer is
running slow right now I don't know why
but I use paint.net
yeah see here's all kids moves
thumbnails
I'm sure miss click will come on I tried
I sent both of the messages and they
just they just don't respond like and
I've gotten to the point now where you
know after I've asked you once twice Max
like you know I'm just not doing it
anymore because I I used to you know hit
people up all the time and it's just
like
you know we already have a huge schedule
so you know sometimes people have to
wait months to come on mag magic I think
mag's been on
I do think bag has been on let me look
and I think that's like my my biggest
issue it's just like
I think
I've gotten to the point where it
doesn't bother me as much but sometimes
I do get frustrated because I'm just
like you know I don't want
I I want them on to hear their
perspective and they and that they they
love gaming and that's why I get annoyed
when some of them don't respond
yes she is on Twitch uh she's on YouTube
too
guys need to check out these reviews man
I've been really putting a lot of work
into these reviews
uh
appreciate the sharing the website
what website did I share just to be on
the safe side I don't know website or
sure I will share
she's in a Nintendo gamer girl guys guys
has been on before I'm pretty sure yeah
guys it's been on
foreign
oh yeah
um it's called paint.net that's what
it's called paint.net
and it's pretty simple for the most part
I don't think you have too many issues
with it
it's a simple thing man it's a simple
thing
I got to get like overlays man you know
maybe start doing these like every
Friday maybe Saturday I don't know yet I
just got to figure out uh
you know right now I'm unemployed
currently
uh long story I don't want to really get
into it uh so once I get another job I
got to see exactly how that's going to
take my time before I can really
dedicate more time into doing stuff but
right now I don't have a job so it's a
lot easier for me to be flexible
should bring a guest from Community once
a month to go over one or two topics
um you talk about besides IOP
cares what you mean by that small uh
Creator Workshop
uh what do you mean uh Workshop just
just to clarify
uh wavering
Galaxy fighter what are you guys talking
about enlighten me I think I'm confused
a little confused
you guys got to tell me a little bit
can't trust some people to be honest
yeah there's a lot of uh a lot of shady
people in the community
was your YouTube Community yes oh you
maybe I don't know if we would do it on
IOP though to be honest with you because
we just got so much going on with IOP
and so many guests and stuff you know
maybe with these little things because I
do plan on streaming more on my YouTube
channel but I'm not there yet for those
that want to make a channel on their own
uh yeah
now
if you want to make a channel on your
own
I feel like there's a lot of options
that you can make for instance I would
focus more on audio than anything else
you know video visual stuff that can go
I mean hell you don't even have to show
your face half the time most of these
people don't even show their face but
you don't have to show your face and I
feel like you can do fine without
showing your face but you know that's it
the content's good that's if you have
good chemistry if you do a podcast the
biggest thing that you're going to want
to do just make sure people can
understand you correctly and then you
build up get to get the community uh get
the the webcams and go from there
but you know I don't I remember one time
I was in a podcast with Danny and he
said you know just get out there and do
it and I do agree with that to a point
you want to figure out what kind of
content you want to make and what kind
of uh influence you want to be in the
first place before you start really
investing heavenly
but you know if you got like an extra 50
60 bucks lying around I think
you definitely need to evolve and all
you need to invest in audio like you got
to
and it's just so many people got you
know mics now so many people have mics
like just a mic like this
just a mic like this
Mike's like 150 bucks and you know
that's a lot to a lot of people it's
definitely a lot to me I would kill I
wouldn't kill for 150 bucks but you guys
get what I'm saying
um you know
when it comes to stuff like that
I don't get artwork don't get a camera
get a decent mic you know you can get a
plenty of options that you can get a
decent mic that people can hear you for
under 50 bucks
and to me if people want to get into
this Lane and they want to make content
they want to do podcasts
you know 50 bucks isn't a lot of an
investment I mean I have thousands
invested into this thousands literally
thousands
and you know
but that's it's like building blocks you
don't do it all at once you you get
what's important first and I think audio
is the most important thing you can have
and then after you get the audio then
you keep building it and keep building
it
you know
I have a stream deck I have a computer I
have a three
I have a three monitor set up I have a
Sony 6400 camera
and you know I have an Elgato light on
the top right I need another one on the
left eventually
got a boom mic with uh it's a Cheryl I
believe this is a share of mic with uh
with the zoom podcasting thing I you
know and we didn't get this all at once
it took years to accommodate all this
and you know got all you guys to thank
for you know if something goes wrong and
I need something for the podcast to you
know make sure that something stays
revelant you know the games that we
review if if I don't get a review code
how you guys think I get that that I I
am they get send me the money to go
purchase that and I we can do that
because of you guys because you guys
support us so much you like the content
we give
you know we've built a community that
I'm generally proud of I really am like
you know it's it's nice
to be to have a community
that respects you uh because they
because there's a lot of communities out
there that does not respect the content
creators that they're following
uh
I think that's a very subjective
question uh it would be hard for me to
answer that uh Antoine
I don't know man some of the old final
fantasies have really good uh
soundtracks
I would play more of them but I don't
want to get like hit for copyright or
anything like that so I want to be a
little bit careful what I put
for the most part I'm trying to just
stick to uh
just something off Bethesda because for
the most part I've seen Bethesda don't
really care too much if you play their
music
but don't play don't play anything I
don't know like a lot of these
soundtracks are in the actual games and
if you're streaming the games I feel
like you can play the soundtrack
like I feel like that makes sense
you know what's funny is just like the
passion
that
The Gamers have for the industry
it's just it's intense man we love this
this we love it
and that's why I get so annoyed when I
see people trying to infiltrate
the gaming industry that don't love it
for a job like I I get it some people
you know you got riders that that went
to school for riding and they couldn't
get into the actual industry that they
wanted to get into
and they're using gaming to make a money
off of their their mouth and I get that
but part of me is like
the industry is full of people that can
write and that actually love games they
generally love games and they don't and
some of them don't get those
opportunities because you have people
that would prefer to hire someone that
is an expert at writing instead of
someone that's good at writing uh but
the other person's better and I get it
like it's all semantics but to me
if you're a genuine gamer and you're
reading stuff you can sense that that
person actually loves that brand if they
love the games that they're talking
about and I think that's the part that
gets on my nerves
have you done a Bethesda game series
let's play oh no I haven't I have not uh
depends on what you're talking about you
know we're talking about the Fallout
games the
there's a bunch of them man passions of
us agree passions a month and keep in
mind I you know the majority of you
should be subscribed to IOP but if you
ain't hit that subscribe button man
because every one of us is passionate
about this industry every single one of
us loves this industry
so I think uh I went a little longer
than I intended on you know I played I
played scoring for like an hour and a
half it's it's a I got a lot to say on
IOP got a lot to say play all them on
steam or in a video okay how would you
guys feel since uh some of you are
members is I do more let's plays and
stuff but I put it in the member stuff
now I don't want to do that I don't want
to clog the the YouTube channel but I I
do personally feel like people that go
and be above and beyond financially you
know we can we we need to do better on
insinuating them and rewarding uh you
know going that way you know people show
up they they like the podcast and they
watch it uh but I do feel like
especially myself I need to try to make
it a little bit better for the people
that are like members people that's on
the patreon you know they get a lot of
perks but you know I've always felt like
you know
what's what I want to say this I always
thought gaming is our brand and for the
most part you know gaming should be
front and center and anything attached
to it should be like a patreon or member
stuff for instance you know if we do TV
stuff uh anything like that uh I I
personally would like any anything
that's not gaming that is what's in the
members and stuff because uh but I get
it you know we to a point financially
for us especially if we want to go to
these shows and stuff we gotta we gotta
really go above and beyond for uh for
people that go above and beyond for us
uh you know showing up we do the show we
read the super chats we do whatever we
can but to a point we do have to what's
what I'm looking for
we have to consider all long term as
well
uh you you all have interviewed yeah and
and well uh when we have a lot of
interviews go uh to the playlist and
you'll see IOP exclusive interviews
there's a lot of them actually
scoring has so much potential to be a
hit Triple A game with good right with
good writer and director the game felt
more like a concept in the making than a
finished game
not going to go too much into that OJ
um I want to I want
to to to to talk about the scoring thing
but I got to get off here in a couple
minutes and I do want to leave I want to
say the bars for IOP you guys definitely
hit that that Bell icon down there
you'll see exactly what my thoughts
process on scoring is
all right but I'm going to go ahead and
uh close out of here you guys I
appreciate you guys coming through man
you you came in here at hardcore and I I
really appreciate it you know I'm trying
to do better on a lot of things and I
feel like you know I I need to do better
on certain things especially with the
interrupting during the show I've tried
to improve that what it is I have ADHD
and I'm like right now I'm literally
shaking my leg just to like keep it
under control and I've done it my whole
life and sometimes it's hard for me to
keep in an opinion because I just want
to say it so fast so much if that makes
sense
but I am trying to improve on that so
all right so this is what I want you
guys to do man yeah you guys have been
here
for two hours and 16 minutes
go over there to 108 Dragon my homie 108
Dragon tell him addict sent you from IOP
man do that for me man go over there and
listen to the Nate solid podcast I think
you guys would like it man go over there
and listen to them I uh unfortunately I
can't route you guys there because uh
they don't have us permission to route
you there but go over there tell them
addict sent you
from Iron lore's podcast go over there
and listen to that show man it's good
show I'll talk to you guys later